bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
journal sur TVfil 78 nous sommes le
mercredi 25 février 2015 et dans
l'actualité evvelinoise aujourd'hui le
Conseil d'État a tranché l'élection
municipale à voisin le Bretonneux annulé
le recours porté par Alexis Biet
l'ancien maire vient d'aboutir face à la
nouvelle élue Alexandra Rosetti les
réactions les conséquences dans ce
journal une femme de 32 ans et son fils
de 4 ans sont porté disparu depuis
vendredi dernier les autorités pensent
que cette femme d'origine congolaise
demeurant à guillancour est en voie de
radicalisation elle serait partie faire
le djihade en Syrie et puis le fromager
de Rambouillet est devenu meilleur
ouvrier de France Ludovic bizo sacré
lors de la compétition qui vient de se
tenir au Salon de l'Agriculture à Paris
nous irons aussi à la rencontre tout à
l'heure dans ce journal de ce qui
représente le département sur ce
rendez-vous contournable il faudra donc
revoter à voisin le Bretonneux les
élections municipales annulées le
Conseil d'État a rendu sa décision cet
après-midi rappel des faits 30 mars 2014
les électeurs accordent 15 voix d'avance
à Alexandra Rosetti udi face à Alexis
Biet UMP le maire sortant ce dernier
proteste auprès du Tribunal
Administratif évoquant des éléments de
nature à avoir faussé le scrutin si le
tribunal administratif rejette C cette
protestation le Conseil d'État a donc
décidé de suivre les demandes de
l'ancien maire Alexis Biet bonsoir
bonsoir je voudrais tout simplement pour
débuter votre réaction à l'annonce de
cette décision du Conseil
d'État écoutez elle est simple hein le
Conseil d'État qui est la plus haute
juridiction administrative de notre pays
et bien a retenu que de graves et
multiples violations du code électoral
ont été commises pendant la la campagne
et ont altéré la sincérité du du scrutin
il n'y avait qu'une quinzaine de voix
qui vous qui vous séparent euh
effectivement le Conseil d'État a jugé
que c'était de nature à avoir faussé un
petit peu le le scrutin mais est-ce que
cela signifie maintenant que vous avez
obtenu en quelque sorte gain de cause
que vous serez candidat dans 3 mois on
peut imaginer que c'est à peu près le
délai qui sera retenu pour
l'organisation c'est la préfecture qui
va s'en charger mais ce sera environ 3
mois de de délai d'autant qu'il y a des
élections départementales bientôt donc
cette question est-ce que vous serez
candidat dans 3 mois écoutez ce n'est
pas une question de de personne hein euh
simplement euh euh le Conseil d'État
confirme que tout n'est pas permis euh
dans une compétition électorale et que
force doit rester à la loi alors mon cas
personnel n'est pas du tout important
dans dans le respect du du droit et et
des règles nous nous réunirons en équipe
et nous déciderons effectivement comment
doit-être composé l'équipe hein c'est
tout à fait ouvert ce n'est pas du tout
une question
personnelle pour moi quand vous dites
c'est ouvert ça veut dire que vous
imaginez ne pas être tête de liste au
prochain SCR municipal mais bien sûr
vous savez j'ai toujours été je dirais
porté par mes équipes pour en prendre la
tête et je ne cherche pas du tout à à
m'imposer je je ne l'ai jamais fait je
vois pas pourquoi je ne continuerai pas
donc il y aura une décision interne avec
vos anciens colistiers vous allez vous
vous réunir rapidement j'imagine tout à
fait tout à fait on va se réunir
rapidement
et nous souhaitons hein que cette
nouvelle campagne est bien
soit vraiment l'occasion pour chacun de
s'exprimer dans le respect des autres et
des valeurs de la République pourquoi
avoir décidé malgré tout de mener ces
procédures on va tout de même rappeler
que vous siégez dans la majorité à
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yveline
voisin le Bretonneux appartient à la
communauté d'agglomération de 50 ans en
Yveline vous siégez ensemble avec
Alexandra Rosetti ça ne va pas
déstabiliser d'une certaine manière la
droite à 50 ans en Yveline cette
décision je pense que tout le monde se
souvient que nous n'avons pas attendu le
résultat du 2è tour pour manifester euh
notre surprise notre étonnement
euh par rapport aux pratiques qui ont
été faites par l'équipe de Madame
Rosetti et que nous avions après le
premier tour déposer un un procès-verbal
au commissariat de police de de
Billancourt donc c'est par simplement je
dirais que reconnaître que c'est règles
ont été bafoué que la démocratie a été a
été trompée hein et
donc on se doit en en politique et bien
d'être exemplaire je crois que en ce
moment l'abscension est de plus en plus
importante parce que il y a un certain
rejet de de la classe politique et bien
là c'est un exemple comme quoi et bien
la justice fait son œuvre pour que
justement ces manœuvres soit dénoncé
mais pour revenir sur le fond de ma
question vous n'avez pas peur que cela
déstabilise la droite à 50 an en Yveline
encore plus au-delà des des contestation
que vous aviez pu émettre après dès le
premier tour mais mais là aujourd'hui
avec cette décision du Conseil d'État je
vous pose cette question parce que très
simplement l'agglomération de 50 an
yeline s'apprêtait à voter son budget au
mois d'avril là il s'avère que puisque
c'est la procédure hein tous les élus de
de de de voisin le Bretonneux vont être
suspendus sur la commune et au sein de
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline donc il n'y a plus une majorité
importante suffisante en tout cas pour
voter le budget en l'état on peut
imaginer que le président de la
Communauté d'Agglomération va décider de
reporter le vote vous n'avez pas peur du
de déstabiliser donc la droite tout
simplement écoutez je ne suis pas du
tout maître de la décision c'est une
décision du Conseil d'État et je m'y
PL et je ne suis pas maître du
calendrier
donc maintenant que cette décision a été
prise je pense que il y aura des
aménagements des des autorisations et
exceptionnel qui seront donnés à la Glo
pour qu'elle puisse voter son son budget
un petit peu plus tard et nous ne
représentons que je dirais qu délégués
sur 48 mais vous le savez cette majorité
est très très serrée au sein de
l'agglomération 4 délégués ça peut ça
peut tout changer sur scrutin oui
écoutez je ne pense pas qu'en ce moment
vu l'état de de la gauche les équilibres
changent merci Alex bi d'avoir réagi dès
ce soir à l'annonce cet après-midi du
Conseil d'État qui a décidé donc de
valider cette annulation du scrutin
municipal de mars dernier à voisin le
bretonne dans votre commune je précise
qu'alexibiet sera sur ce plateau demain
en direct dès 18h première rediffusion
du journal à 19h vous le savez je vous
précise également que nous avons
sollicité la mère de voisin le
Bretonneux Alexandra Rosetti qui pour
l'instant n'a pas souhaité livrer de
commentaires quelles conséquence en tout
cas pour l'agglomération de 50 ans en
ivelé nous l'avons vaguement évoqué il y
a quelques instants comment réagit la
chef de fil du Parti socialiste à cette
décision qui vient ébranler malgré tout
les rangs de la droite et du centre on
écoute Sandrine grandom c'est au micro
de Catherine zulato et de Patrick
Jacques de
dixmud non c'est quand même une surprise
parce que le en première
instance c'est aexbiet n'avait pas eu
gain de cause même si moi les arguments
qu'il faisaient valoir me paraissaient
quand même assez intéressant notamment
le fait que il y a des règles qui font
qu'on n' pas le droit de de distribuer
des tractes le samedi qui précède
l'élection parce que ça faut
l'élection et comme ça s'est joué à très
peu de voix après on est dans une guerre
des droites à voisins qui pénalise
aujourd'hui tout le monde parce que
pratiquement 1 an après l'élection on se
retrouve dans une situation qui est
quand même assez inattendue où les
vcinois n'ont plus de conseil municipal
plus de maire et où à la gllo il y a
plus de majorité pour faire passer quoi
que ce soit donc à moins d'arriver à
travailler gauche- droite dans dans un
consensus pour essayer d'avancer
intelligemment mais pour l'instant il y
a plus de majorité dans l'équipe de
Michel logier
et nous reviendrons demain sur cette
annulation du scrutin municipal à voisin
le Bretonneux avec d'autres réactions
notamment celle sans doute d'Alexandre
arosetti qui s'exprimera et puis de
Michel logier le président de
l'agglomération de 50 ans niveline qui
n'était pas joignable en cette fin de
journée dans l'actualité locale
également le territoire éelinois
particulièrement propice à la
radicalisation religieuse c'est le
préfet qui l'évoquait au début du mois
de février et l'on apprenait hier le
départ probable d'une femme guyant
courtoise de 32 ans pour la Syrie et les
précisions de Mélanie
poquet c'est l'étonnement et
l'incompréhension qui règne en mairie de
Montini ce mercredi quand les agents
découvent chez nos confrères du Parisien
un article signalant qu'une animatrice
de la maison de quartier André Merot
située dans le quartier des prê serait
parti faire le djihad en Syrie la jeune
femme de 32 ans était employée en
qualité d'animatrice famille elle avait
donné sa démission et quittait son poste
jeudi dernier c'est samedi qu'elle
aurait rejoint la Turquie avec son fils
de 4 ans en mairie on précise que
l'équipe de la maison de quartier a été
abassourdi par la nouvelle elle ne
montrait aucun signe de radicalisation
ni dans ses propos qui étaient cohérents
ni dans ses vêtements la semaine
dernière elle a encore assisté à une
réunion d'équipe et tout s'est très bien
passé explique-ton en mairie la
municipalité précise travailler de
concert avec l'association dir afin de
mener un travail de sensibilisation
auprès des jeunes de la ville la mairie
a aussi demandé à l'association des
musulmans de Montini de faire preuve de
vigilance du côté de la mairie de
guillancour où résidait cette jeune
femme et sa famille aucun commentaire à
apporté la mairie dit avoir découvert
l'affaire dans les colonnes de nos
confrères du
Parisien hier au salon de l'agriculture
c'était la finale de la 5e édition du
Concours du Meilleur Ouvrier de France
classe fromager 10 candidats qui ont
participé aux épreuves finales elles ont
durer tout de même près de 5h parmi eux
Ludovic bizo le fromager donc est
installé à rambbouillet il a dû réaliser
un chef-dœuvre sur le thème Retour vers
le Futur une mise en scène
exceptionnelle avec 25 fromages
d'appellation d'origine contrôlée et ses
qualités ont été reconnues à 48 ans le
senior de la compétition a été consacré
Meilleur Ouvrier de France ils ne sont
que deux cette année à avoir convaincu
le jury une belle reconnaissance pour
cet IV Linois natif de Lyonne qui s'est
reconverti dans la profession il y a 6
ans écoutez son témoignage un défi
réussi un défi personnel comme le comme
l'escalade d'un haut sommet donc une
sorte de défi sportif un trempelin aussi
pour évoluer dans le fromage ça donne
des possibles ça ouvre des portes ça
permet pas je parle pas forcément de de
business mais aussi de d'avoir
l'occasion d'être un ambassadeur du
fromage et du métier partout en France à
l'étranger et cette 52e édition du Salon
de l'Agriculture qui a lieu en ce moment
même Porte de Versailles ce sont 700000
visiteurs qui sont attendus pour
l'événement sur les standand on retrouve
des agriculteurs des producteurs
yvelinois qui sont venus défendre leur
profession leurs produits et faire la
promotion aussi de ce département des
Yvelines sur place Floran parfait O
William l qui sont allés déguster les
spécialités
locales une journée au salon de
l'agriculture ce n'est pas de tout repos
une véritable aventure entre les
concours de fromage et de beauvin on
peut même déguster une glace ivinoise
les sorbets ont un succès fou ouais un
bon petit cornet pendant les allées
c'est vraiment top des glaces mais aussi
des confitures des jus et des pâtes de
fruits c'est la première fois que la
ferme du Louie située près de Toir est
présente au salon de l'agriculture pour
présenter ses produits on se fait
connaître bon c'est c'est vraiment super
on vend nos produits on vend les
produits dérivés de de la cuueillette
mais ce qu'on voudrait vraiment c'est
donner l'adresse de notre ferme aux gens
on dit que c'est les ivelines c'est le
poumon vert de de la région parisienne
et il faut que tout le monde que tout le
monde le sache pour les agriculteurs
évelinois c'est aussi l'occasion de
croiser des têtes connues et même de
décrocher quelques récompenses tous les
ans on présente nos produits avec quand
même plutôt des des bons résultats tous
les ans donc régulièrement on a on a des
médailles sur différents produits et
cette année on a une médaille d'argent
sur le yaourt à la framboise donc on est
assez content parce que c'est un produit
qui avait jamais été médaillé donc ça
permet d'avoir plusieurs produits
médaillés sur sur toute la gamme comme
la ferme de Grignon à Plaisir la ferme
de villetin proche de joui en Josa s
habitué du Salon de l'Agriculture
l'établissement est réputé pourtant pas
question de manquer cet événement
décisif pour agrandir sa clientèle salon
de l'agriculture c'est d'abord la
présentation que tout le monde voit les
plus beaux animaux de de toute la France
et aussi c'est un contact et ben de de
tous nos clients qu'on peut avoir alors
voyez quand on les reçoit je garde pas
mon tablier je vais prendre ma
veste d'abord parce qu'il fait froid
dehors pour les accueillir on fait une
très belle visite du salon où je leur
présente les les animaux et puis on
finit sur notre stand avec un petit jus
de pomme de la ferme une véritable
opération séduction pour la dizaine de
producteurs et agriculteurs Vinois
présent sur le salon pour les
retardataires l'édition 2015 fermera ses
portes le dimanche 1er
mars les invités de ce 25 février à
présent Kevin leguedois et Stéphane
valzac respectivement président et
technicien de la Fédération des
Chasseurs d'île-de-fance bonsoir à tous
les deux la saison de la chasse qui va
se terminer le 28 février tout d'abord
un mot sur votre club pourquoi un club
des jeunes chasseurs ben on a ce club a
été créé par un administrateur il peu
peu près plus de 10 ans à d'engendrer la
la courbe inverse etess de motiver les
les jeunes à la chasse donc là il y a
deux buts principal donc c'est fédérer
les jeunes autour de la chasse et de et
de leur proposer des invitations de
chasse afin qu'ils puissent pratiquer
leur passion dans dans les meilleures
conditions possibles et quand vous dites
motivez les jeune ça veut dire que
jusqu'à présent il y avait un désamour
de de cette passion là mais le problème
c'est qu'en île-de-fance la chasse elle
est très coûteuse où l'accès au
territoire est très difficile donc via
l'association les jeunes chasseurs ont
des invitations gratuites sur sur des
territoires en î-defance et en en
province quoi quand vous dites c'est
coûteux c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce qui coûte
cher dans la pratique de la chass
comment ça fonctionne tout d'abord mon
le permis de chasser coûte 16 € pour
pour un jeune après il y a une
validation une taxe qu'on doit payer
tous les ans qui qui est d' l'ORD de 200
€ pour un permis départemental et après
il y a l'action de chasse et les actions
de chasse on trouve une action de ça à
partir de 400 € jusqu'à des prix
exorbitants quoi 400 € pour pouvoir
pratier sur un territoire à un moment
donné en fait voilà pour avoir chasse
sur le territoire être chasseur
aujourd'hui et je vais vous poser la
question à tous les deux ça signifie
quoi être chasseur
aujourd'hui être chasseur aujourd'hui
c'est comme c'est comme hier disons
c'est être en contact avec la
nature continuer un petit peu ce que nos
nos parents nos grands-parents faisaient
c'est-à-dire essayer de maintenir un
équilibre avec la nature puisque la
nature n'est pas un un équilibre et
c'est un perpétuel déséquilibre mais
l'homme est là pour essayer de maintenir
cet équilibre essayer de de juguler
certaines populations animales essayer
de de régler les les problèmes de
surpopulation qu'on a par endroit par
rapport aux dégâts de de gibier les
dégâts agricoles puisque que ce soit les
sers les sangers ou les chevis il faut
bien qu'ils se nourrissent et ils vont
principalement dans les cultures dans
les cultures blé maïs col et cetera ce
qui nous coûte très cher puisque les
chasseurs indemnisent les dégâts
agricoles donc être chasseur aujourd'hui
c'est euh c'est aussi un style de vie
c'est d'être toujours au contact de la
nature puisqu'on s'aperçoit
qu'aujourd'hui s'il y a s'il y a a 40 ou
50 ans 80 % des chasseurs étaient des
ruraux aujourd'hui 80 % des chasseurs
sont des urbains sont des gens qui sont
qui vivent dans à la ville ou en ville
disons quasiment toute la semaine et le
weekend s'échappe à la campagne les
chasseurs indemnisent c'est-à-dire que
vous êtes pénalisé en tout cas puni
parce que vous avez mal fait votre
travail de régulation non non non c'est
que les chasseurs ont pris en charge la
gestion des espèces et en voilà en
disant c'est nous qui gérons enfin on a
ça été proposé il y a il y a une
quarantaine d'années en disant voilà
nous on va gérer les populations animal
et s'il y a des dégâts c'est nous qui
payons voilà donc et c'est payé à 100 %
par les par les chasseurs dans le
département des iines par exemple cette
année on a à peu près 500 à 600000 €
d'indemnisation de dégâts que nous
versons aux agriculteurs l'année
dernière on é 8 les associations
fédération qui payent c'est sont les
adhérents directement les chasseurs de
leur poche voilà ce sont les chasseurs
quand ils prennent leur permis de
chasser payent une cotisation qui sert
voilà qui sert uniser les agriculteurs
voilà le rôle est particulièrement
important de la chasse vous venez de
l'entendre mais comprenez-vous ce rôle
des chasseurs c'est notre question du
jour et puis vous pourrez réagir juste
après mais oui c'est
important parce qu'il faut tuer les
animaux qui sonent en trop la chasseur
oui c'est pour ça sport et puis pour
réguler un peu la la nature bon après ce
qui se passe c'est il faut pas que ça
soit outrance non plus mais il faut
effectivement oui pouvoir réguler le le
flot des animaux par la chasse ce que je
le comprends bah peut-être que c'est
nécessaire pour éradiquer des espèces
qui pollue mais mais voilà sinon j'ai
pas d'autres sentiment par rapport à ça
a priori oui en campagne notamment moi
je sais que j'ai mes j'ai mes oncles en
campagne dans le dans les svenes ils
sont envahis par les sangliers et s'il y
avait pas le rôle des chasseurs je pense
que ça ferait de vrais dégâts je suis
pas trop pour dans le sens c'est violent
mais après ça a une utilité il y a
plusieurs choses alors sur l'aspect
sport et violent déjà est-ce que vous
voulez réagir il faut pas que ce soit
outrance il faut que ce soit encadré
aussi euh justement oui tout tout toute
la l'art disons la subtilité c'est d'
arriver à trouver cet équilibre
effectivement faut ça soit violent la
chasse par définition on tue l'animal
quand même hein c'est la finalité
maintenant on ne tue pas n'importe quoi
on tue pas n'importe quand la chasse est
très réglementée c'est l'activité de la
nature qui la plus réglementé puisqu'il
y a un code de l'environnement qui s'est
disons qui encadre tout ça les période
de chasse les animaux à prélevés à quel
moment quel le matériel utilisé c'est
très très cadré on ne prend pas fusi et
on va pas dans un bois comme ça derrière
chez soi c'est c'est c'est pas comme ça
que ça se passe effectivement donc pour
certaines personnes ça peut paraître
violent
mais la chasse enfin disons la nature
par elle-même elle est elle est violente
hein puisque ce sont les lois
élémentaires de la nature quoi dans le
microrottoir on entendait aussi parler
de la campagne les gens comprennent le
rôle des chasseurs leur importance à la
campagne mais malgré tout ici on est un
peu plus en ville sur CS en yeline mais
par exemple les sangliers viennent de au
cœur de 50 ans eneline et cré des
dégradations tout à fait les animaux bah
les animaux colon hein il y a pas un
territoire pour les hommes et un
territoire pour les animaux l'homme va
sur le territoire des animaux les
animaux viennent sur les territoire des
hommes et on a des animaux on a des
sangliers on a en permanence confronté à
ce problème ici sur la communauté de
commune de Saint-Quentin on a des
animaux qui rentrent dans le parc du
château de Versailles on a sur satori
sur Buc on a des des sangliers qui
rentrent un peu partout des chevs il
colonisent donc bah il faut essayer de
de bah quand il y en a quelques-uns que
c'est pas c'est pas gênant au contraire
et puis en plus les les gens ont plaisir
à les rencontrer par contre quand ça
commence à ça peut surprendre le soir
voà voilà problème ça quand ça commence
à poser des problèmes de collision sur
les routes ou détérioration des jardins
des espaces publics des terrains de FO
et cetera là on intervient parce que
voilà la c'est saison de la chasse qui
se termine donc le 28 février là à la
fin de la semaine quelle bilan on peut
faire est-ce qu' un bilan qui est dressé
sur des espèces qui seraient peut-être
menacé d'ailleurs comment ça se passe au
niveau de la régulationun anné sur
l'autre ça change en fait on suit toutes
les populations animales on travaille
sur plus de 50 espèces on fait des
contat en permanence et on suit ça va de
la loouette jusqu'au ser et on suit donc
toutes ces populations animales en
fonction de leur densité l'année d'après
ben on en tue plus ou on en tue moins on
adapte les prélèvements par rapport aux
objectifs qui sont fixés par le préfet
par l'administration par les
agriculteurs par les sylviculteurs bon
chacun a un objectif différent bien sûr
mais on essaie de de de de conjuguer
tout ça et de façon à trouver la la la
moins bonne enfin la meilleure solution
quoi au niveau de de de de chaque espèce
parce que d'une année d'une année à
l'autre les conditions cl climatique il
y a tellement de facteurs qui qui
peuvent intervenir sur sur la
reproduction sur l'évolution des
populations que ça soit les oiseaux
migrateurs qui partent dans d' autres
pays il peut y avoir des problèmes de
d'incendie de de de de canicule et
cetera ce qui fait que on a jamais les
mêmes densités d'une année sur l'autre
donc c'est à nous chasseurs de nous
adapter voilà la saison de la chasse qui
se termine ça veut dire que les
chasseurs sont au chômage comment ça se
passe une période hors chasse qu'est-ce
que vous faites pendant cette période
donc il a 6 mois de chasse après il y a
6 mois de gestion l'entretien des
territoires comme a dit Stéphane les
comptages euh dès la semaine prochaine
on on attaque les comptages de grand
servid sur le massif de
rambbouiller il y a les salons où ça
nous permet de nous rencontrer et
l'aménagement l'entretien des ha les
agré noirs après va voir les les les
faisants les perdis qui qui vont mettre
bas donc va voir chantinage des
compagnies pour savoir si la
reproduction était bonne et puis on va
arriver au mois de septembre qui où on
va pouvoir rechasser tout le travail
qu'on a fait durant 6 mois moi on va
avoir le bénéfice au mois de septembre
quoi donc vous allez pas être au chômage
vous aurez forcément des activités merci
à tous les deux d'être venus en plateau
donc technicien à la Fédération des
chasseurs d'île-de-fance et président
des jeunes chasseurs pardon
d'île-de-fance on parle d'environnement
à présent on reste un petit peu dans la
même thématique avec l'association les
Croqueurs de pommes qui proposent chaque
année des animations et en cette période
et c'est la taille des arbres fruitiers
qui est au programme plusieurs d'entre
eux sétaient donné rendez-vous à Manil
et un mot pour entretenir pommiers et
poiriers alors on travaille sur la
partie haute mais on pour redescendre un
petit peu sur le bas parce qu'on oublie
des choses fin février les arbres sont
en plein repos végétatif c'est la bonne
période pour la taille des pommiers et
des poiriers ce jour-là une quinzaine
d'adhérents de l'association les
Croqueurs de Pommes a fait le
déplacement on fait des animations dans
le terrain de de particulierers qui ont
la possibilité d'avoir des des supports
des arbres déjà existants bien sûr qu'on
peut tailler et qui permettent de faire
un cours de taille la taille c'est
l'entretien annuel à faire pour que les
arbres refleurissent ou donnent des
fruits correctement elle varie en
fonction de l'arbre de son âge et de son
état la première chose en matière de
taille c'est d'apprendre à reconnaître
les ce qui pousse sur un arbre on
appelle ça les organes végétatifs il y a
des choses qui donnent du bois il y a
des choses qui vont donner des fleurs et
des fruits il y a des choses qui vont
donner des rameau très vigoureux
d'autres choses qui vont donner des
rameau faibles il y a deux types de
taille taille de fructification et de
formation quand les arbres sont jeunes
on les forme on achète un arbre on le
plante et on commence donner une forme
pendant 4 5 7 8 10 ans on le forme autre
type de taille la restauration pour les
arbres tropagés ou abîmés c'està-dire
qu'on rajunit les AR on rajunit par la
taille par des tailles parfois un peu
sévères on rajeunit et on refait on
refait on fait du jeune avec du vieux on
va dire la cinquantaine d'arbres de ce
jardin a pu profiter de l'atelier il ne
le reste plus qu'à
fleurir un mot de santé à présent
Florence est manioise depuis une dizaine
d'années elle a deux enfants et l'un
deux Liam 14 ans souffre de troubles
appelés 10 depuis l'âge de 7 ans lorsque
ces troubles héréditaires ont été
détectés il est suivie par une
orthophoniste et depuis l'année dernière
une auxiliaire de vie scolaire l'aide
dans ses devoirs dyslexie disgraphie
disorthographie c'est le nom des trois
troubles contre lesquels Liam se bat
tous les jours sa maman nous l'explique
et elle témoigne voici un extrait de son
témoignage la suite sera à retrouver
dans notre prochain magazine santé
checkup donc il a une moyenne de
concentration qui est largement
inférieure à la moyenne de son âge donc
très vite il est fatigué donc ça peut
être un quart d'heure 20 minutes de
concentration en cours et après donc
faut qu'il se repose l'esprit on va dire
mais et donc ce qui fait que il
papillonne et il se repose l'esprit pour
pouvoir se reconcentrer après euh bah la
disgraphie donc un enfant qui est
illisible qu'on ne peut quasiment pas
relire et la 10orthographie ben
c'est je suis suui tu es et T
c'est tout tout c'est du phonétiique en
fait au niveau scolarité il y a pas
vraiment d'aide où les enseignants ne
peuvent pas dire à un parent votre fils
est dyslexique ou autre chose mais
seulement proposer une aide extérieur
donc après c'est tout un parcours que
les parents doivent faire et souvent
c'est seul parce qu'on sait pas comment
le
faire le dossier complet sur ce thème
donc préparé par yolen Torres je vous le
disais sera à découvrir dans le prochain
numéro de checkup magazine santé
bien-être de TVfil 78 diffusion à partir
du 13 mars c'est la fin de ce journal je
vous redonne l'information du jour
l'annulation du scrutin municipal de
voisin le Bretonneux 15 voix séparé
l'ancien maire Alexis biatu MP et sa sa
première adj reindre son ancien adjoint
udi élu en mars dernier Alexandra
Rosetti le Conseil d'État saisi par
Alexis Biet a donc choisi de faire
revenir les électeurs aux urnes en
attendant le préfet va nommer des
administrateurs pour les affaires
courantes je vous renvoie au replay sur
notre site internet si vous souhaitez
entendre les premières réaction ça a été
diffusé au tout début de ce journal et
puis demain jeudi Alexis Biet sera sur
ce plateau et lors du 78 politique du
mardi prochain nous reviendrons encore
plus en détail avec les différents
protagonistes autour de cette table dans
ce studio le journal de demain vous sera
présenté par Catherine zulato je vous
souhaite une excellente fin de
semaine